Why are some people incredibly likable,
but nobody takes them seriously? How can
somebody be incredibly intelligent, but
when they talk, they sound unsure of
everything they're saying? And how can
somebody smile tell you in real time
whether or not they're being genuine or
fake? In this video, I want to help you
one, uncover what makes someone likable.
Number two, how to be more respected.
And number three, how to stop others
from misreading you. I learned these
lessons from a powerful communication
book called Q's by Vanessa Van Edwards.
And when I learned them, I look back at
my own career and my own entrepreneurial
journey and I go, "Ah, that actually
explains a lot." If you're new here, my
name is Vin and for more than a decade,
I've been an international keynote
speaker, a communication skills coach,
and now I've actually just become an
author. Yes, I [cheering and screaming]
finally done it. This is my book, Before
We Forget How to Connect. I'm super
proud of what I've been able to do. And
yet, my mom still isn't. She still
wishes that I was an accountant or
become an accountant. And when I reflect
on the journey of writing over the last
year, it made me think a lot about the
authors and the books that have shaped
me and the teacher that I've become
because they gave me a language for the
things that I could never explain, even
though I felt it and experienced it
myself. So, I wanted to celebrate all of
the authors over the next few months
that have been inspiring me all along in
my journey as I release my book.
Starting with Q's, I'd love to share
with you the three lessons that have
stuck with me the most. And the first
idea that Vanessa teaches explains why
you can be incredibly talented and
brilliant at what you do, yet people
still don't connect with you. And it all
comes down to what she calls charisma.
Vanessa explains that when we meet
someone, we're looking unconsciously for
two things. Warmth, which means, can I
trust you? Competence, which means, can
I rely on you? And the people we call
charismatic, they give us cues of both.
When I learned this, I thought about my
career as a magician because I was
incredibly competent. I was obsessed
with slot of hand, and I'd spend hours
on one tiny move that most people
wouldn't even notice. But when I perform
for people, do you know what I'd say?
Watch. Watch, watch. I was basically the
early career David Blaine without the TV
deal. I was so focused on doing
something impressive that I forgot there
was a human being in front of me. And I
made it all about me. And this is what
Vanessa's framework helped me see. Being
good at something doesn't automatically
make people feel good around you and
feel good about you. I had developed one
side of the equation and completely
neglected the other side. So, I started
learning showmanship [music] and that's
essentially how to create warmth. I
learned to tell stories, to be more
playful and expressive with my voice and
my body language. And I stopped
performing magic at people and I started
performing with them. And here's the
bigger thing that I got wrong. I thought
there was only one version of me as a
performer at that time in my career
early on. I was quiet. I was serious. I
was trying to be mysterious. I was
trying too hard to be mysterious that it
came across a little bit weird. And I
just thought that was who I was. That's
my personality. That's the way I use my
voice. And that's the way I perform. And
anytime I would perform in any other
different archetype or different version
of myself, being a little louder, being
a little more charismatic, I just
thought, "Oh, no. That's that's that's
not me. That's fake. That's phony." But
I want you to think about this. Let's
say you play piano. You're not a fake
pianist or a phony pianist. If you play
jazz on a Friday and then on Saturdays
you decide to play classical, you've
just unlocked a whole new version of
yourself, a whole new genre that you
have access to. And that goes for your
voice, too. That goes for you as a
performer, you as a communicator, you as
a human being. You developing range and
learning the art of storytelling,
learning how to use your voice in a
different way. It's not you being
performative, again, fake or phony.
[music] It's you giving people the
opportunity to experience more of you.
So start to explore all the different
parts of your communication because you
can create warmth with your voice. You
can create warmth with how you use your
body language and you can also create
warmth in the words you choose to use.
This is the real secret to connection.
It's not just about competence. It's
also about warmth. That whole idea
became a huge part of the reason why I
called my book Before We Forget How to
Connect. It's actually available for
pre-order now. And the whole book is
really about how do we expand our vocal
range for so people can connect with
more of us. How can we learn how to use
more of our body language to express
what we're thinking, what we're feeling,
and the ideas that we have to share? How
do we tell stories that allow people to
understand more of us deeply? And how do
we listen in a way that lets you
understand them more deeply, more
clearly? Because I don't want to turn
you into a different person. I want to
help more of the person that you already
are become visible to the rest of the
world. the links in the description if
you do want to pre-order my book. And
I've got a QR code on screen as well
[music] because if you do pre-order this
month, you also get a free ticket to
join me live online for 3 days at an
event that I'm running called Break the
Mold. And we'll learn how to use the
entire instrument to be able to
gradually learn how to express more
warmth, more assertiveness, how to
become more humorous. You'll be doing it
with me live next month. Uh, okay. Now,
back to Vanessa's brilliant book because
there's another tiny cue that completely
changes how people experience you. Which
brings us to lesson number two. It's
about upspeak. And I don't want to
explain to you what it is. I want you to
experience it. Listen to this. I've been
teaching communication for the last 10
years and I'm certain that I can help
you solve all your communication issues.
Do you trust me? No. I'm telling you I'm
certain, but my voice says otherwise.
That's upspeak. It's when your pitch
rises at the end of your statement, like
you're asking me a question, like me
saying, "My name is Vin. I'm the CEO."
The words say, "I know what I'm talking
about." But the voice says, "Wait, do
I?" The very moment I read about this in
cues, I thought about a student of mine,
a doctor, incredibly intelligent, really
capable, and she said something I hear
all the time. Then the men in my
industry, they never take me seriously.
Now, I want to be really careful here
because gender bias is real. I'm not
pretending it's not. But when I heard
her communication, there was also
something happening there that's within
her control. Every statement sounded
like she was asking permission. I think
we should move forward. Maybe we could
try this. And her body was doing the
exact same thing because your voice and
your body are connected. And an unsure
voice creates unsure gestures. So we
worked on both. We brought her pitch
down at the end of her statements. And
automatically this translated to her
having more authority and certainty with
her hand gestures. And we actually
worked on one more thing. She would
begin her sentences with the words I
think. I feel like, maybe, sort of. So
instead, I got her to swap it out for
[music] two words. I believe. The
difference was immediate. And notice it
didn't make her more intelligent. She
was already intelligent. She's a doctor.
All we did was adjust a few small cues.
And now she comes across with more
authority and was able to command more
respect. And this is the part I often
think about. We become the things we
repeatedly practice. [music]
So if you practice sounding unsure, then
uncertainty is going to feel like your
natural voice. And eventually you are
going to say, "Ah, Vin, that's just who
I am. I'm an unsure person. I'm an
uncertain person." But what if that's
not your identity? What if it's just
your rehearsal history? What you've been
practicing? Because if one behavior can
be rehearsed, a different one can be
rehearsed, too. Your communication, it's
not a life sentence. And now for the
final lesson, the smile. Being a great
communicator isn't just about the cues
that you're sending away to other
people. It's also about being present
enough to notice the cues that you're
receiving from other people. When I
first started performing, I couldn't
really see my audience. I mean, I could
see them, but my whole mind was on the
mechanics, the next move, the angles.
Don't flash. Don't screw this up, Vin.
But once you've practiced something long
enough, the mechanics actually become
automatic. And suddenly you're in this
situation now where you've got more
cognitive capacity left over to be
present in the moment. And when I became
more present, I started reading faces.
Vanessa talks about one cue in
particular, a genuine smile. A real
smile isn't just in the mouth. It
reaches the cheeks and shows up around
the eyes. It's often called a dishen
smile. And as a magician, I know this
expression well because there's this
moment when someone absolutely has no
idea how the trick has happened and they
lose control of their face completely.
Their mouth smiles, their cheek rise,
their eyes smile. It's pure
astonishment. That's when I know I've
got them. The controlled little smirk is
different, though. That one tells me
they're thinking, they're analyzing,
they're trying to catch me. The face is
giving me information in real time. And
this is where a lot of us go wrong.
We're so busy thinking about what we're
going to say next that we've literally
got no brain power left to be focused on
the other person. So, we end up missing
all of the cues from the other person
who's directly in front of us. The
reason we practice our voice, our body
language, and storytelling isn't so that
we just become obsessed with the
technique forever. You practice the
skill until the skill needs less of your
brain power so you have more available
for them. And maybe these are the
biggest lessons I took from Q's. It's
that communication is always happening
in two directions. The cues you're
giving and the cues you're receiving.
The better you get at understanding
both, the smaller the gap becomes
between the message you're meant to send
and the experience the other person
actually had. Vanessa, thank you so much
for giving me the language and
frameworks to understand this. Cues is
an amazing book. You got to get it. You
got to read it. Those are only a few of
the lessons from this amazing book here.
So, give her a follow on social media.
That's book number one. I've got 11 more
brilliant books in this series and 11
more authors I want to give some love
to. Oh, and I almost forgot. If you want
to pre-order my book before we forget
how to connect, the link is down below
in the description and the QR code is
somewhere on screen. And he's put it on
my face, hasn't he?
Damn it. He's put it on my face. You can
scan that code on my face right now. And
don't forget, there's a pre-order bonus
waiting for you.